if we could talk for just a brief moment
about the human
of putin and power
you are clearly fascinated by power
do you think power changed putin
do you think power changes leaders if
you look at the
great leaders in history whether it's
lbj
fdr do you think power really changes
people like is there truth to that kind
of old
proverb it reveals i think that's what
it is
it reveals so putin was a much
more deft politician much more amenable
to the west
if you think back you know to 2001 and
more right when he came because he was
still
because at that time his biggest problem
was intra-russian politics
right like it was all consolidating
power within the oligarchy
once he did that by around like 2007
there's that famous time when he spoke
out against the west at the munich
security conference i forget when it was
and that's when everybody in the
audience was like whoa and he was
talking about like
nato encirclement and like we will not
be beaten back
by the west very shortly afterwards like
the georgia invasion happens
and that was like a big wake-up call of
like we will not be pushed around
anymore
i mean he said before publicly like the
worst thing that ever happened was the
fall or
what did he say it was like the fall of
the soviet union was a tragedy right
yeah of course people in the west were
like what i'm like i get it right like
they were a superpower
now their population is declining like
it's like a petrol state it sucks
like i understand um i understand like
how somebody could feel about that
i think it revealed his character um
which is that he i think he thinks of
himself
probably as he always has since 2001
as like this benevolent almost as a
benevolent dictator he's like without me
the whole system would collapse
i'm the only guys keeping these people
in i'm the only guy keeping all these
people in check
most russians probably do support putin
because they feel like they support some
form of
functional government it's like a check
against that which is a long you know
has a long history
within russia too so i don't know if it
changed him i think it just revealed him
um because it's not like he i mean he
has a bit you know navalny has put that
like billion dollar palace and all that
i don't know sometimes i feel like putin
does that for show
he doesn't seem like somebody who
indulges in all that stuff or maybe we
just don't see it like i don't know well
i don't
i it's very difficult for me to
understand i've been hanging out thanks
to clubhouse
uh a lot of i've gotten to learn a lot
about the
navalny folks and it's been very
educational
made me ask a lot of important questions
about what
um you know question a lot of my
assumptions about what i do and don't
know
but i'll just say that
i do believe you know there's a lot of
the novelty folks say that putin is
incompetent
and there's a is a bad uh executive like
is bad at
basically running government but to me
why do russians not think that though
right well they they probably
would probably press yeah they would say
the control there there is a
strong either control or pressure on the
press
but i think there is a legitimate
support and love of putin in russia
that is not grounded in just
misinformation and uh propaganda there's
there's legitimacy there
mostly i try to remain apolitical and
actually
genuinely remain up apolitical i am
legitimately not interested
in the politics of russia of today
i feel i have some responsibility and
i'll take it that responsibility on as i
need to but
my fascination as it is perhaps with you
in part
is in the historical figure of putin i
know he's currently president
but i'm almost looking like as if i was
a kid in 30 years from now reading about
him
studying the the human being
the the games of power that are played
that got him to
gain power to maintain power what that
says about
his human nature the the nature of
the bureaucracy that's around him the
nature of russia
the people all those kinds of things as
opposed to the politics and the
manipulation and the corruption and the
control of the media that results in
misinformation
you know those those are the bickering
of the day just like who were saying
what will actually be remembered about
this moment in history totally he's a
transformational figure in russian
history really like the bridge between
the fall of the soviet union and the
chaos of yeltsin
that will be how he's remembered the
only question is what comes
next and what he wants to come next
that's i'm always fat i'm like
he's getting up how old is he 60
something yeah 60 so he would be
i think he would be 80 so with the with
the change of the
constitution he cannot be president
until uh
2034 i think it is so he would be like
80 something
and he would be in power for over 30
years which is longer than stalin
so but he's still he still seems to be
he seems fit i think he's going to be
around for a long time
but this is a fascinating question that
you ask which is like what does he want
i don't know yeah that's the question i
don't i uh and this is where
i think given all this behavior and more
i don't know if it's about money
i don't know if it's about enriching
himself obviously he did to the tune of
billions and billions and billions of
dollars
but i think he probably he's as close to
like an actual russian nationalist
like at the top who really does believe
in russia
as its rightful superpower everything he
does seems to stem
from that opposition to nato intro to
syria like wanting to play
a large role in uh affairs
deeply distrustful and yet coveting
of the european powers like look i could
describe
every czar you know in those same
language like every czar falls into the
exact same category
you